Fünf Tage, 200 km, bis -20 °C.
Mit dem Husky-Gespann
quer durch die Wildnis Lapplands.
Vier Frauen und ein Mann
erfüllen sich einen Traum.
* Treibende, mystische Musik
mit Gesang *
20 Std. Dunkelheit.
Eine Reise,
die sie an ihre Grenzen bringt ...
... aber auch
ihr Leben verändern wird.
Es ist eine so grosse Bereicherung.
Das ist prägend.
Das ist etwas vom Besten, was ich
in meinem Leben je getan habe.
Es ist einfach alles perfekt
und es tut mir so gut.
Genau das, was ich nötig hatte.
Es ist eigentlich Wahnsinn,
innerhalb von vier Tagen
eine solche Bindung
erleben zu können.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Fünf Tage zuvor.
Das Abenteuer startet
100 km nördlich des Polarkreises
auf der Husky Ranch
von Juho Ylipiessa
im finnischen Kurtakko.
Es ist Anfang Dezember 2019.
Gemeinsam mit seiner Frau Hanna
betreut Juho hier 29 Alaskan Huskys.
Hanna wird in den nächsten Tagen
auf die Ranch aufpassen müssen,
ihr Mann Juho wird mit den
Schweizer Abenteurern unterwegs sein.
Die Bedingungen auf den Trails
sind gut.
Ich meine, ich würde es lieber
ein bisschen kälter haben.
Aber ich bin zufrieden,
dass die Seen gefroren sind.
Und die Eis- oder Schneeschicht
ist immerhin 40 cm dick.
Die Trails sind wirklich gut.
Das ist nicht selbstverständlich
für diese Jahreszeit.
Juho und Hanna
haben seit 2009 Schlittenhunde.
Juho fährt mit ihnen zwei bis drei
Langstreckenrennen pro Winter.
Doch meistens ist er in dieser
Jahreszeit mit Touristen unterwegs.
Fünftägige Touren
sind aber eher selten.
Unsere Hunde sind sehr sozial.
Sie brauchen die anderen Hunde,
aber auch unsere Liebe.
Sie haben
ganz verschiedene Charaktere.
Manche sind ganz begeistert
von neuen Menschen,
andere sind etwas reservierter.
Nicht aggressiv, einfach skeptisch:
Wer ist diese Person?
Die Hunde verhalten sich anders
mit uns als mit den Gästen.
"Abenteuer Lappland"
ist auch für Juho und seine Huskys
eine willkommene Herausforderung.
Am Anfang sind wir
auf einfachen Streckenabschnitten,
die für Tagestouristen
präpariert sind.
Aber weiter draussen gibt es dann
kurvigere Teile, steilere Hügel.
Wir fahren durch Gebüsch und Wälder.
Und wenn wir Glück haben, gibt es
sogar einen oder zwei Schneestürme.
(Frank Senn) Unsere Serie
heisst "Abenteuer Lappland".
Wird es ein Abenteuer?
Definitiv,
das kann ich versprechen.
* Bellen *
Bevor das Abenteuer morgen beginnt,
spannt Juho seine Hunde
für ihre tägliche Trainingsrunde
vor sein Schneemobil.
Huskys sind voller Energie
und wollen v.a. eines:
rennen
und in der Natur unterwegs sein.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen und Jaulen *
* Helle, perlende Musik *
* Jaulen *
Die Schweizer Gruppe ist unterdessen
in der Dunkelheit Lapplands
angekommen.
Die vier Frauen und ein Mann
haben sich bis jetzt nicht gekannt.
Eine HR-Managerin
und eine Physiotherapeutin,
eine Software-Testmanagerin,
der Brunnenmeister aus Giswil
und eine Psychologin
mit musikalischer Ader.
# Chumm, mir waged s Abentüür,
z obe hocke mir chli ums Füür.
Sie haben sich auf einen Aufruf
von SRF DOK gemeldet.
Was sie verbindet:
der Wunsch, für fünf Tage
aus ihrem Alltag auszubrechen.
Und die Liebe zu Hunden
und zur Natur Lapplands.
Mach einen Engel!
- Die erste Schneeschlacht.
Bevor es losgeht:
die letzte Nacht in Ylläsjärvi.
Zeit, sich besser kennenzulernen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich habe 30 Jahre lang
ein Geschäft geführt
im Bereich Sanitär/Heizung.
Ich hatte Glück
und konnte es vor vier Jahren
einem Mitarbeiter übergeben.
Ich habe immer gesagt,
mit 55 muss sich etwas ändern.
Und ich habe eine tolle Familie,
bin seit 30 Jahren verheiratet.
Eine Tochter und einen Sohn
etwa in eurem Alter.
Ja, und jetzt bin ich von Beruf
Brunnenmeister.
Ich bin viel in der Natur draussen.
Mein grosses Hobby, meine
grosse Leidenschaft ist die Jagd -
also auch wieder Natur.
Ich war schon immer
viel in der Natur.
Ich habe auch Familie. Meine
erste Aufgabe ist, Mutter zu sein.
Das mache ich sehr gerne.
Ich habe drei Kinder,
sieben, fünf und drei Jahre.
Und ich bin Psychologin,
arbeite und doziere an der Uni.
Ich mag auch viel anderes.
Musik ist etwas,
in das ich Zeit investieren will
und das ich geniesse.
Entsprechend ist meine Woche voll.
Daneben gibt es aber auch viele
Beziehungen, die ich pflegen möchte.
Meine Ehe,
die ich gesund erhalten will.
Das ist auch eine Herausforderung.
Ich geniesse diese Dinge,
aber ich merke auch,
es ist ein Balanceakt
zwischen all diesen Aufgaben.
Es heisst ja, als Mutter kümmere
man sich zu wenig um sich selbst.
Deshalb fand ich,
ich will das nur für mich machen.
Ich wohne
in einem kleinen Dorf im Aargau,
somit bin ich
das Landleben gewohnt.
Ich arbeite aber in Zürich
in einem Grosskonzern
in der Personalabteilung,
wo ich die Personalverantwortliche
für die Regionen Südostschweiz,
Ostschweiz und Zürich bin.
Mein Arbeitsbereich
ist also auch mit Reisen verbunden.
Ich habe die letzten eineinhalb
Jahre in mich selbst investiert -
mit Weiterbildungen - aber auch
im Job hatte ich die Möglichkeit,
mehr Verantwortung zu übernehmen.
Man kann es sich vorstellen:
Jeder Bürojob bringt mit sich,
dass es Stress gibt
bzw. diese getakteten Termine.
Genau das war eine Motivation,
warum ich mal
aus diesem Alltag ausbrechen wollte,
aus diesem Schnelllebigen, in
eine Umgebung, die total anders ist.
Ich bin ursprünglich mal
Bob gefahren,
war Spitzensportlerin.
Ich liebe den Schnee,
ich liebe Kufen, schnelle Kufen.
Ich bin gespannt,
wie schnell die Schlitten fahren.
Auch die Kälte macht mir nichts aus.
Ich bin aber gespannt,
wie es bei -20 bis -30 °C wird,
wenn wir kochen
und das Zelt aufstellen müssen.
Ich freue mich.
Ich liebe Abenteuer.
Ich liebe es,
aus der Komfortzone rauszukommen.
Es bringt einen weiter,
vergrössert den Horizont.
Man kann immer dazulernen.
Ja.
Ich bin eigentlich ziemlich quirlig.
Ich habe sehr viele Hobbys.
Ich habe einen Traumjob
als Software-Testmanagerin
im Versicherungsbereich.
Ich mache das schon seit 20 Jahren
mit Herzblut.
Ich habe vor fünf Jahren
die Diagnose einer Nervenkrankheit
bekommen, Parkinson.
Das hat mich dann etwas ausgebremst.
Auch meine Reiseaktivitäten
musste ich zurückschrauben.
Diese Reise gibt mir Hoffnung.
Sie gibt mir Kraft.
Das erhoffe ich mir auf jeden Fall
von der Natur.
Ich hoffe, von der Natur
Ressourcen ziehen zu können.
Und von den Hunden.
Mein körperlicher Zustand
wird immer schlechter,
nicht besser.
Auch wenn ich die Medikamente
einnehme, ist es nicht zu stoppen.
Es werden nur
die Symptome zurückgehalten.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich
nächstes Jahr noch gehen kann,
denn ich kenne den Verlauf nicht.
Ich weiss nicht,
was auf mich zukommt.
Das war ein grosser Faktor,
warum ich mich gemeldet habe.
Ich hoffe, dass es mir
noch lange so gut geht wie jetzt.
Wenn mich jemand fragt, sage ich:
"Mir geht es wirklich gut."
Dezember 2019.
Statt Schnee und Minustemperaturen:
Regen.
* Unheilvolle Klänge *
Wie vor jeder Tour
bekommen die Hunde am Morgen
besonders proteinreiche Nahrung.
* Bellen *
Juho?
Was sagst du zum Wetter?
Ich weiss nicht,
ich kann gerade nichts sagen.
Eigentlich wären im Dezember
Minusgrade normal.
Aber auch hier oben in Lappland
muss man sich
an neue Wettermuster gewöhnen.
Ich sah es leider kommen.
Schon den ganzen Herbst über
hatten wir Temperaturschwankungen.
Aber bis Freitag
sollten wir wieder bei -16 °C sein.
Unterdessen sind die Schweizer
auf der Farm angekommen.
Oh, wow!
- Good morning.
(Alle) Good morning.
Ihr seid also meine Gruppe.
Hallo.
Hi, I'm Juho.
- Barbara.
Silvia.
- Juho. Nice to meet you.
Armin.
Martina. Nice to meet you.
- Juho.
Willkommen auf der Husky Ranch.
Ich wünschte,
wir hätten besseres Wetter.
Ich weiss,
ihr wollt die Hunde treffen,
aber zuerst werden wir euch
bessere Kleider besorgen.
Und dann werfen wir
einen Blick auf die Karte,
wo wir in den nächsten fünf Tagen
unterwegs sein werden.
Gehen wir rein,
der Regen ist schrecklich.
Habt ihr so was schon gemacht?
Wie viel Erfahrung habt ihr?
Keine Erfahrung.
- Keine Erfahrung.
Halbtagestouren.
Okay, die schönen, die einfachen.
Die mache ich normalerweise auch.
Tagestouren.
Eine einstündige Tour.
Okay. Also wenigstens
ein bisschen Erfahrung.
Das Ganze ist einfach.
Wenn ihr Hunde und die Natur liebt,
dann ist das schon mal
ein guter Start.
Denkt daran, wir werden weit fahren.
Deshalb müssen wir
als Team zusammenbleiben.
Du darfst das Team nicht verlieren.
Punkt.
Wir fahren zuerst 5 km durch Wald.
Dann kommen wir
in dieses grosse Naturreservat.
Das grösste Sumpfgebiet Europas.
(Deutsch) Der grösste Sumpf -
korrekt so?
Die Tour beginnt 100 km nördlich
des Polarkreises in Finnland.
Von Kurtakko führt sie am ersten Tag
35 km durch das grösste Sumpfgebiet
Europas in die Wälder Lapplands.
Am zweiten Tag folgen 46 km,
am dritten Tag weitere 38 km
mit dem steilen Anstieg
auf den Aalistunturi.
Und am vierten Tag folgt
die Königsetappe mit über 50 km,
den gleichen Weg zurück ...
... bevor es am fünften Tag
wieder zur Ranch geht.
Inzwischen
hat es aufgehört zu regnen.
Die Teilnehmer
lernen ihre Hunde kennen.
Let's go and see the dogs.
- Yes! - Juhu!
(Barbara)
That's the best part for us.
(Juho) Alle sind nett,
ihr könnt überall hingehen.
Keiner beisst.
Eto ist yours as well.
Das wird dein Hund sein, Silvia.
Er wird
direkt vor dem Schlitten laufen.
Er ist stark.
Mayday wird in der Mitte sein.
Das ist die Mutter von Mayday.
Die schwarze, Irny.
Ich werde sie nicht
ins erste Team nehmen,
sondern irgendwo in der Mitte.
Sie wollen nur noch los. Das ist
für sie ein Zeichen zum Aufbruch:
wenn Leute in dieser Kleidung
hier stehen.
Mayday.
Ja, sie hören auf den Namen.
Mayday ist erst einjährig und war
noch nie auf einer so langen Tour.
White Socks
könntest du auch heissen.
Armin.
Ist das einer von deinen?
Das ist Ballack,
dieser schwere Hund.
Der Monsterhund!
Der passt zu mir,
das hat er gecheckt.
Armin der Brunnenmeister
hat den grossen, starken Ballack
im Team.
Es ist sehr berührend.
Dass einem ein Wesen so nah ist.
* Lockere Musik *
Es sind alle sehr herzig.
Dieser hier ist sehr ruhig.
Der andere ist ganz verspielt
und rennt rum.
Es ist spannend, wie man
die verschiedenen Typen spürt.
Charaktere wie bei uns Menschen,
sehr verschieden.
* Aufgeregtes Bellen *
Jede und jeder wird während der Tour
für sein eigenes Gespann
mit fünf Hunden verantwortlich sein.
Zuerst heisst es, Schlitten packen
mit Essen für sich und die Hunde,
dem eigenen Gepäck
und dem Campingmaterial.
Jeder Schlitten
wiegt so bis zu 60 kg.
Auf der Tour müssen sie
die Hunde versorgen, Camps aufbauen
und v.a. die Kontrolle
über das Gespann nicht verlieren.
So.
Wir gehen
die Fahrinstruktionen durch.
Wenn wir unterwegs sind,
gibt es drei einfache Zeichen.
Das hier heisst langsamer.
Ihr bleibt mit dem Fuss
auf der Bremsplatte.
Das heisst Stopp.
Steht auf die Metallbremse!
Und wenn wir angehalten haben,
müsst ihr auf der Bremse bleiben.
Wenn die Pause länger ist,
dann setzt ihr sogar den Bremsanker.
Aber auch der hält nicht sicher.
Auch wenn wir anhalten,
behaltet ihn im Auge!
Und wenn ihr runterfallt,
was passieren könnte ...
Das passiert immer wieder.
Wenn ihr also so runterfallt
und hier hängt, lasst nicht los!
Das ist die wichtigste Regel.
Lasst den Schlitten nicht los!
Wartet, bis die Hunde anhalten!
Steht wieder auf die Bremse,
atmet tief ein und fahrt weiter.
Putzt eure Kleider ab,
dann wird niemand wissen,
dass ihr runtergefallen seid.
* Lachen *
Siehst du?
- That's important, don't lose face.
So, wir spannen zuerst
die Leader ein.
Und denkt dran,
diese kleinen Kreaturen
werden die Seile durchbeissen,
wenn ihr nicht aufpasst.
Also schaut immer wieder,
dass die Hunde noch da sind.
Irny ist die schwarze da hinten.
* Wildes Bellen *
Armin, lass die Hunde nicht raus!
Don't let them run away.
Tür zu!
Zieh ihm das Geschirr im Zwinger an
und komm mit einem Hund raus.
Öffne nicht die Tür,
sonst rennen sie raus.
Dräng sie zurück!
Na, jetzt geht es bald los.
Gut so?
Completely.
Perfekt so.
Ihr müsst euch kennenlernen, wie?
Hey, aber seid lieb!
Lieb sein.
Ihr müsst lieb sein.
Kaum sind die Hunde eingespannt,
wollen sie losrennen.
Juho versucht,
alles unter Kontrolle zu behalten.
* Helle, perlende Musik *
Dann endlich: Juho gibt das Zeichen
für den Start der Tour.
Die Reihenfolge ist klar definiert,
jeder hat seine Position.
Doch ausgerechnet
Bobfahrerin Michelle
kann ihre Hunde
nicht mehr zurückhalten.
Hey, löse deine Bremsen
nicht zu früh.
Kontrollier dein Team,
stell dich auf die Bremse!
* Lautes Bellen und Jaulen *
* Treibende Musik *
Dann endlich geht es los.
Es ist 12 Uhr.
Herrlich ruhig.
Die Hunde trippeln.
Das ist
eine wahnsinnig schnelle Piste.
Ich muss immer
leicht auf der Bremse stehen.
* Mystische, treibende Musik *
Und da ist es,
das Gefühl von Freiheit.
Davon haben sie alle geträumt.
Eine Stimmung, speziell, mystisch.
Die Tage im Dezember sind kurz,
nur 4 Std. Dämmerlicht.
Nach 14 Uhr ein erster Stopp,
noch bevor
die Dunkelheit hereinbricht.
Essenspause, auch für die Tiere.
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
15 km haben wir schon.
Mittagspause.
Auf Silvia
wird Juho ein Auge werfen.
Wegen ihrer Parkinson-Erkrankung
stellt die Tour für sie
eine besondere Herausforderung dar.
Es ist traumhaft, ein super Start,
superschönes Wetter.
Es ist einfach ... geil.
Ich habe grosse Freude,
ich bin happy.
Mega.
Dank Medikamenten führt sie
ein weitgehend normales Leben.
Ihr Arzt gab grünes Licht
für die Tour.
Okay, come to this side.
We're going to take
those dogs closer.
Pass auf, dass die Hunde
nicht deine Leine durchbeissen.
Fantastisch!
Man kann es mit Worten nicht
beschreiben, einfach wunderschön.
Es ist, als würde man
über den Schnee fliegen.
Hier in Lappland
gibt es diese Weite,
die wir in der Schweiz nicht haben.
Kannst du uns bitte helfen, Juho?
Das Seil muss einige Male rum,
dann der Knoten.
Noch klappt nicht alles.
Geduld ist nicht meine Stärke.
Am Anfang ging es so schnell,
sie sind einfach los und dann ...
Aber mit der Zeit lief es besser.
Sie haben unglaublich viel Kraft,
das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Das ist Wahnsinn.
Sei vorsichtig mit den Fingern.
Sie lieben diese Würste.
Okay.
Das ist fast schon gemein.
So, hier.
Die Hunde erhalten
ein Stück gefrorene Wurst.
* Bellen, Fiepen *
Viel Arbeit, an die sich
das Team noch gewöhnen muss.
Ich nehme jetzt mal wieder ...
... meine Drogen.
Meine Medikamente.
Oh.
So.
Ich muss sie regelmässig,
zu bestimmten Zeiten einnehmen.
Sonst bricht mein Dopaminspiegel ein
und dann kann ich mich
nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich bin jetzt schon
ziemlich langsam.
Das ist das Dopamin,
das mir durch die Krankheit fehlt.
Ich habe so eine Box,
die ich jeden Tag vorbereite.
So weiss ich immer,
welche ich wann einnehmen muss.
So.
Die Hunde wollen weiter.
Sie haben erst den halben Weg
zurückgelegt. Keine Distanz für sie.
Dann etwas,
wovor sich jeder Musher fürchtet:
Einer von Silvias Hunden
hat sich am Vorderlauf verletzt.
Eine Wunde,
die verarztet werden muss.
Damit hat Juho nicht gerechnet.
Schon am ersten Tag
ein solcher Zwischenfall.
Noch weiss er nicht, ob die Hündin
Sony überhaupt weitermachen kann.
Weisst du, was passiert ist?
Keine Ahnung.
Sie muss irgendwo
hängengeblieben sein.
Es ist nur die Haut,
sie hat keine Schmerzen.
Ich gebe ihr
etwas Entzündungshemmendes.
Ich werde jetzt
nichts auf die Wunde tun,
sie würde es nicht drauflassen.
Aber wenn wir im Camp sind,
dann werde ich
einen Verband anlegen müssen.
No niin.
Noch bleibt die Hündin Sony
im Gespann.
Sie scheint auch begierig darauf,
weiterzurennen.
Hundeführerin Silvia hatte
die Verletzung selber nicht bemerkt.
Was ist denn?
Auf der Seite? Ah, hier.
Was hast du getan?
Wahrscheinlich ein Ast.
* Bellen und Jaulen *
Vielleicht hat sie
einen Ast oder so etwas gestreift,
irgendwie im Vorbeigehen.
Wenn wir vom Sumpf weg sind,
muss ich jemanden anrufen,
damit sie
mit dem Schneemobil abgeholt wird.
Es ist besser, wenn sie heimgeht.
Ich habe nicht gemerkt,
dass ich Hunger habe.
Zuerst muss sich
auch die Gruppe noch stärken,
denn die Kälte zehrt an den Kräften.
Good.
Jetzt hast du nur noch
einen Führungshund, Silvia.
Wir müssen es so versuchen,
wir haben keine andere Wahl.
Traurig, wenn man schon so früh
auf Wiedersehen sagen muss.
Juho wird Sony vorerst
in einer Box platzieren,
die er
hinter seinem Schlitten herzieht.
Er nimmt das Ganze gelassen.
Die Verletzung
scheint nicht allzu schlimm,
aber er will
keine Infektion riskieren.
Das ist nicht ganz,
wie ich es geplant habe.
Die Box war für die Alten
oder die ganz Jungen gedacht,
nicht die Verwundeten.
Sieht aber ziemlich nett aus
hier drin.
Was soll man tun?
Lasst uns weitergehen,
bevor wir noch mehr Hunde
in den Krankenwagen packen müssen.
Seid ihr bereit?
Jetzt habe ich schon
einen Hund im Wagen.
Verrücktes Mädchen. Zu viel
Geschwindigkeit und zu wenig Hirn.
(Barbara) Really?
Es muss weitergehen,
denn die Gruppe ist spät dran.
Es ist zwar erst 15 Uhr,
doch schon stockfinster.
* Treibende Musik *
Das Abenteuer hat begonnen.
Kurz darauf wieder ein Stopp.
Hündin Sony muss nach Hause.
* Juho gibt den Hunden Kommandos. *
Hyvä.
Ich glaube, es geht ihr gut.
Sie ist fast eingeschlafen.
Vielleicht war sie faul
und wollte es sich
einfach nur bequem machen.
Jetzt kann sie heim zu Hanna.
Vielleicht darf sie sogar
ins Haus rein.
Hoppla.
Mein erstes Baby,
das nach Hause muss.
Aha, er holt sie jetzt.
Oh, aber es ist besser so.
Nicht dass sie dann
noch leiden muss.
Ein richtiger Profi.
Professional athlete.
Vielleicht
weil ich es nicht gemerkt habe
und nicht sofort reagieren konnte.
So war der Start nicht geplant.
* Mystische, elektronische Musik *
Jetzt gehen wir weiter.
Nun sind es nur noch vier Hunde,
die Silvias Schlitten ziehen müssen.
Allerdings seien diese vier
stark genug, sagt Juho.
Armin macht den Schluss
in der Schlittenkolonne.
Seine Hunde sind die kräftigsten,
aber auch die wildesten.
Nach 3 Std. Fahrt gegen 17 Uhr:
das erste Nachtlager mitten im Wald.
Hier sind wir.
Camping site.
Hier ist es schön.
Sucht euch alle einen Baum.
Na?
Ihr seid ein gutes Team.
Doch einer fehlt - Armin.
Es herrscht etwas Chaos.
Ein Hundeschlitten ist weg.
Echt?
- Ja, Armin ist irgendwie ...
Er ist auf den falschen Weg geraten
und verschwunden.
Zum Glück passierte der Fehler
so nah am Etappenziel.
So hat Juho
Armins Gespann schnell gefunden.
Sie sind
auf die falsche Seite abgebogen.
Ich liess etwas Abstand,
weil sie so viel Power haben,
dann kam die Abzweigung
und sie gingen nach rechts.
Ich hatte keine Chance.
Ich hätte nach links gehen sollen.
Ich bin dort hochgefahren,
dann sind wir umgekehrt
und jetzt sind wir zurück.
Als Erstes
müssen die Hunde verpflegt werden.
Bevor wir für uns schauen,
versorgen wir die Hunde.
Wir geben ihnen halbgefrorene Wurst,
damit sie schon
etwas im Bauch haben,
bevor das richtige Nachtessen kommt.
Gut.
Ja, fein.
Ballack, hier.
Ja.
(Lachend) Das schmeckt ihnen.
Jeder Hund sucht sich
sein eigenes Plätzchen.
Du bist schon etwas müde, nicht?
Unsere Lady.
Sie hat selbst
das Heu herangescharrt
und hat sich hingelegt
und eingerollt.
Das ist ihr Bett,
von dem sie nicht mehr aufsteht.
Als ich das Geschirr abnahm,
bewegte sie sich ganz wenig,
aber hier geht sie nicht mehr weg.
Silvia präpariert
den Hundehauptgang.
Fleisch klopfen.
Zu Hause macht das mein Freund. Er
muss immer das Fleisch zubereiten.
Das Fleisch ist noch gefroren
und muss zuerst aufgetaut werden.
Juho muss alles kontrollieren.
Es sieht schon fast essbar aus.
Sie brauchen ja
auch noch was zu beissen.
Die Kiste muss voll Wasser sein.
Zuerst kommt das Fleisch rein,
etwa zwei Drittel voll.
Dann füllt ihr es bis oben
mit heissem Wasser auf,
sonst wird das nicht weich.
(Armin) Barbara muss einfädeln.
- Ich bin drin.
Unser gemütliches Zuhause.
Tretet ein!
* Mehrstimmiges Heulen *
Was ist das?
Einer hat angefangen und ...
Ich glaube, es gibt Essen.
- Ah, das Fleisch.
Ich bin stolz auf uns.
Wie lange dauerte es - 5 Min.?
Vielleicht 10 Min.
Aber wir waren schnell.
(Juho) Gib das ruhig
auch den grossen Jungs!
Und wenn ihr ihnen
das Essen hinstellt, passt auf.
Exactly.
Kommt von einer Seite!
Perfekt.
They know how to do it.
Abenteuer Lappland:
Es bedeutet nicht nur Romantik,
sondern auch viel Verantwortung.
Gegen 21 Uhr
die erste Rast des Tages.
Ich geniesse es.
Ich geniesse es in vollen Zügen.
Es ist ...
Ich hoffte, dass es so sein würde,
und ich bin überzeugt,
dass es noch besser wird.
Am Anfang muss man sich
einfach noch etwas finden.
Das hat man gemerkt.
Aber einige Dinge haben super
geklappt, die haben wir im Griff.
Morgen teilen wir alles etwas mehr
auf und helfen mehr mit den Hunden,
dann läuft es.
Als wir hier waren, spürte ich die
ganze Anspannung und Freude und ...
Ich wurde dann auch
richtig emotional.
Diese ganze Freude, was wir alles
erlebt haben. Jetzt sind wir hier.
Aber irgendwie auch:
"Was mache ich jetzt?"
"Was mache ich mit den Hunden?
Was mache ich mit dem Gepäck?"
Am Anfang fühlte ich mich
auch ein bisschen hilflos.
Aber ich glaube, in den
nächsten Tagen weiss man dann,
was man zu tun hat,
wie man es tun soll.
Ich bin froh,
dass ich so gut durchhalten konnte.
Ich hatte grosse Angst davor,
nicht durchhalten zu können.
Aber jetzt habe ich ein gutes Gefühl
für die nächsten Tage.
Ich war sehr beeindruckt,
wie sie das mit dem
Gemeinschaftszelt gemacht haben.
Ich habe mein Team gefüttert
und dann habe ich gedacht:
"Soll ich hingehen und ihnen sagen,
sie sollen das Zelt aufstellen?"
Aber es war schon da.
Das Füttern müssen wir
noch ein bisschen verbessern.
Da ist noch unsere Schwachstelle.
Aber für das Zelt
gibt es schon mal fünf Punkte.
Es gibt diese heilige Regel,
dass man nicht isst,
bevor die Hunde Futter haben.
Sie haben das nicht gern
und werden dich nicht mehr mögen.
(Barbara) All right, in Ordnung?
- Ja.
# Ab id Wildnis, ab in Schnee.
# Zu de Huskys. Häsch sie gseh?
# Chumm, mir waged s Abentüür,
z abe hocke mer chli ums Füür.
# Chumm, mer tauche i diä Welt,
fern vo Hektik ab is Zelt.
# Yeah, jetzt simmer zämecho,
# ufem Schlitte, uf u drvo.
* Lachen *
* Sanfte, mystische Musik *
Es ist morgens um 6.30 Uhr.
Die Nacht war kalt.
(Silvia) Guten Morgen.
Was für eine Nacht!
(Heiser) Super Stimme.
Ich muss pinkeln und dann
Feuer für das Hundefutter machen.
Heisses Wasser für Kaffee, Tee,
die Thermoskannen -
einfach für alles.
Einfach mal etwas Warmes.
Habt ihr gut geschlafen?
Die Hunde warten bereits hungrig
auf ihr Fressen.
Doch die Abenteurer
nehmen es gemütlich.
Zum Missfallen von Juho.
Der Ofen war zwar an,
aber das muss schneller gehen.
Es sollte immer
jemand hier sein und schauen,
dass ständig Schnee schmilzt,
dass es immer Feuer hat.
(Barbara) Eigentlich hätten wir
schnell aufstehen
und arbeiten sollen.
Ich denke, das wird
in den nächsten Tagen besser werden.
Wir sind noch etwas langsam
beim Aufstehen.
Also, an die Arbeit!
Es ist der erste Morgen.
Darum lasse ich das noch durchgehen.
Aber das hier
müsste erste Priorität haben.
Und ich gebe euch noch einen Tipp:
Es ist schön warm hier am Ofen.
Kein schlechter Platz,
wenn du aus dem kalten Zelt kommst.
Vorsichtig, damit ihr nicht die
ganze Stunde Arbeit zunichte macht.
Die Hunde kommen zuerst
und dann die Teilnehmer.
Und jede Minute Verzögerung am Morgen
bedeutet weniger Tageslicht
während der Tour.
Das müsst ihr immer als Erstes
machen, das Wasser schmelzen.
Erst nachher geht ihr auf Toilette
und putzt die Zähne.
Der Ofen hier muss immer brennen,
denn das Schmelzen dauert lange.
So, jetzt machen wir noch Kaffee,
damit Armin aufwacht.
Man weiss noch nicht genau, was
zu tun ist. Das ist das Problem.
(Barbara) So gut!
Ich würde das auch gerne essen.
Das ist sehr fetthaltiges Fleisch.
Und dann kommt noch
das Trockenfutter hinzu,
das viel Protein enthält.
(Juho) That's good.
Barbara ist es, die heute anpackt.
Darauf habe ich mich sehr gefreut -
die Hunde zu versorgen.
Abends, morgens, immer wieder.
(Silvia)
Du hast deine Aufgabe gefunden.
Ich mache das sehr gerne. Das
ist vielleicht die Mutter in mir.
Wenn ich keine Kinder
versorgen kann, dann eben Hunde.
So vermisse ich
meine Kinder weniger.
Nur wenig. Ja?
Die Hunde bekommen rohes Fleisch
mit hohem Fettgehalt,
dazu kommen noch
getrocknete Proteinstücke.
An diese Routine
müssen sich alle erst gewöhnen,
denn sie haben
die Verantwortung für die Tiere.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
* Bellen *
9.30 Uhr.
Eigentlich wollte Juho
bereits unterwegs sein.
Die Hunde sind unruhig,
sie wollen los.
Die Hunde sind sehr aufgeladen,
sie wollen rennen.
Ich rechne damit,
dass irgendetwas passiert.
Damit alle für den restlichen Tag
noch ein Team haben,
bleibe ich hier,
um sie allenfalls zu stoppen.
Und tatsächlich, Juhos Vorahnung
bewahrheitet sich rasch.
Hey, hey!
Zuhinterst bei Armin
herrscht Aufregung.
* Bellen und Jaulen *
Hey, hey!
Armins Rüden Ballack und Cooper
geraten in einen Kampf.
Hey, hey!
* Wildes Bellen *
Wir hatten hier
gerade einen Kampf.
Du musst strenger sein.
Kann ich immer dazwischengehen?
Geh nicht mit den Händen rein,
wenn sie kämpfen.
Aber sag klar Stopp.
Du bist der Chef.
Es dauert alles so lange,
die Hunde werden nervös.
Ich habe eben zu Armin gesagt, dass
er sie nicht streiten lassen darf.
Du musst streng sein.
Wenn du spürst,
dass der Ton zu aggressiv wird,
musst du das sofort stoppen.
Wenn sie sich für 10 Min. anbrüllen,
kann es ausarten.
Hey, jetzt sind die beiden Starken
aufeinander losgegangen.
Das war ein richtiges Knäuel.
Ich wusste nicht, was ich tun soll.
Man muss brutal durchgreifen,
denn die beissen sich gegenseitig.
* Seufzen *
Das war Action.
Aber er hätte mir erklären müssen,
dass ich voll
mit dem Körper dazwischengehen muss.
Das weiss ich ja nicht.
Aber die anderen drei
haben gleich mitgemacht.
Ich hatte plötzlich
fünf Hunde auf mir.
* Mystische Musik *
Dann endlich gegen 11 Uhr,
2 Std. zu spät,
geht es los in die zweite Etappe.
Du musst sie gehen lassen.
Go, go!
Die kriegen wir heute
schon noch müde.
Immer tiefer und tiefer
in die Wildnis Lapplands,
wo weitere Abenteuer auf sie warten.
Achtung, Bäume.